hello everybody markiplier here telling
you that we just hit 13,000 subscribers
holy oh that's quick um yeah so I wanted
to give you guys some stats to show what
has been going on with the channel in
terms of how crazy quick in case you
guys didn't realize it for those people
who are new here we've been growing kind
of quick so here we go here we go views
have increased month month this is all
comparing the last month to this month
views have increased from 318 thousand a
month to seven hundred thirty two
thousand a months for an increase of 130
percent subscribers have increased from
I don't actually have that written down
it's just two hundred and twenty seven
percent from this month's the last month
I think we gained about seven thousand
one hundred eighty seven subscribers
just in the past month alone so that's
pretty damn incredible if you ask me
we've increased likes from twelve
thousand three hundred and eighty five
to twenty four thousand eight hundred
and forty seven month-to-month that's an
increase of a hundred and one percent
favorites have gone from one thousand
two hundred and sixty two to three
hundred and fifty Appa 3521 an increase
of a hundred and seventy nine percent
comments had increased from four
thousand six hundred eighty-three last
month to ten thousand seven hundred and
sixty-seven for an increase of one
hundred and thirty percent at unseemly
no wait no how must have done my math
wrong on that one cuz it no that's right
no that's right that's right yeah that's
right one hundred and thirty percent
yeah yeah yeah okay and shares have
decreased from 1505 shares last month to
nine hundred and eighty-five shares this
month for a decrease of thirty five
percent now don't be discouraged about
that because I did have that big share
promotion for the borderlands to
giveaway last month so that's why it is
um but I mean that that actually is what
sparked it all I think it's just that
started this ball rolling of everything
see this just shows how much you guys
can do when we're all working together
but I'm not disappointed in those
numbers even the share one even if it
decreased it doesn't matter because the
rate of growth has been incredible so
what we're gonna do tonight right at
about 5:00 whenever Bob gets on work
it's off work we are gonna do a drunk
minecraft livestream about two and a
half to three hours of non-stop drunk
action that sounded wrong but you know
drunk minecraft for about two and a half
hours or three depending on how long
we're all able to go for I know people
have things to do but we're gonna
squeeze it in and we're gonna do a live
stream over on the twitch channel you
can click on the link in the description
below go ahead you probably already know
about it but my twitch channel is in the
link in the description below follow me
there you'll get a notification as soon
as you go online and we'll all be
posting a video on here later so I hope
you all enjoy it now I can't keep up
with every thousand doing a milestone
thing as much as I want to it's going so
quickly now with that I want these as
milestones to be special so my next
milestone is gonna be 15,000 and then
it's gonna be 20,000 and then 25 30 40
there are 30 35 40 45 50 and once it
hits 50 and then we'll go 60 70 80 90
all the way to the big 100,000 which is
my goal by June of next year so I wanted
to seem to be special I can't just go
11,000 who's 17,000 Oh 23,000 you know I
it's not special I just keep doing that
and considering comes every three days
or so a new thousand so the race is been
absolutely incredible but yeah every
like three or four days it's in another
thousand so the next one is gonna be
fifteen thousand I have something
special for then and the next one will
be twenty thousand and I'll have
something special for them so thank you
all so much for watching and as always I
will see you at the drunk minecraft at
five o'clock Eastern Standard
about four hours three and a half hours
from one list if you post it just keep
up I'll be in the Twitter's chat room if
you want to chat with me I'll be there
I'll have it I have that chat thing to
open up most of the time so if you ever
want to chat with me I'm easily there so
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I'll see you in the live
stream bye bye